hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreign again
welcome to the second video of today the
first video goes over all the stuff that
we talked about in the blades of Persia
event so pretty much everything you need
to know about that besides the event
pass and the weapons which we are
covering in today's video if you're
watching this video first you can click
the I on the top right or way to the end
of this video there'll be a link to that
video somewhere in the video so like I
said we're gonna be going into the event
pass first and then we're going to be
going into the weapons and kind of
diving into what we're going to be
expecting but what that guys like to be
for doing Joe subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
they hear updates the patch notes and
the leaks if we want to be up to date
with everything happening in the world
of foreigner and miss out an update that
please do subscribe to the channel with
that let's get started with today's
video alright so first up we're gonna be
taking a look at the blades of Persia
battle pass and I've actually haven't
looked at this yet so we're gonna be
experiencing this for the first time so
I've already bought all thirty tears
just to just kind of have them all ready
just the case I wanted to do for extra
footage in the video but the first tier
we have is an outline of course this is
very standard for most of the events and
seeing as this is already free it's
pretty much just like any normal event
soon as you hop on you get the outline
this is pretty much the same premise
then we go to 75 Salvage going on to the
caline's discipline at battle off it's a
battle fo which you probably saw in the
last video this is going to be for all
five of the Wulin then we go to 100
steel we then get the exact same battle
outfit but for all seven of the Vikings
moving on to page 2 we have the samurai
version of the battle outfit going to a
scavenger crate then into the Nights
version of the battle Offutt which
completes all that within the first
eight tiers then we have 100 steel at
tier 9 for tier 10 we move into the
hourglass of Persia ornament not a too
bad of an ornament I must say it's
alright I wish that there was a little
bit more to it I feel like that orange
and red barely go with any outfit in
this game so personally not a big fan
but if that's going to be for all the
vikings then we have the samurai version
at tier 1175 steel or salvage of my
apologies at tier 12 then we have the
ornaments for the Knights at tier 13
steel 100 steal at tier 14 halfway
through we have B
inversion of said ornament gotta say it
being faction based is pretty cool
honestly I'm a pretty big fan of the
woollen one it's very big but once again
this red and orange I'd feel like just
does not sit well with most characters
moving out to the second half of it
we're finally starting to get into some
effects but we have one scavenger great
and then 17 18 19 and 20 is the samurai
Knight Roulin then Viking Idol effect of
the sabba loose at times emote or I saw
a mood effect respectively it's not bad
the the effect itself isn't that bad
I feel like personally they probably
could have grouped all four of these up
into one section but I mean to be honest
for the effect itself it's not bad if
it's at the theme so I'm cool with it
on to tier 5 once again we have a entire
stack here of 75 Salvage and then the
Knights version of Wulin version Viking
version and samurai version of sab
elusive times again but this being the
emo version of said mood effect got the
Knights here got the Wulin I actually
never you know what that's that's a
whole lot better than the idle effects
because this one actually has a lot more
flair to it at the end whereas with the
idle effect if we go back here it's kind
of just a nice sand rollin in in a sense
whereas if it's the emote you could see
if there's a lot of you know there's a
lot of oomph to it right there I think
that's really dope and to the last five
tiers we have 100 steel and ending it
with the Wulin viking Samurai and Knight
version of set loose at times as you'd
expect except the execution version
personally not too bad like I said it's
got that um that a lot of the things
that I definitely like with mood effects
except I don't the raining inferno event
did this and I don't like when the thing
Tora the opponent turns a different
color I feel like it takes away from the
effect maybe that's just me but I feel
like when the opponent turns a different
color like a like a tan as we're seeing
here raining inferno I did this giant
red in a sense I feel like it just takes
away from the entire effect and it just
kind of ruins it for me
overall if I had to give my thoughts I
definitely say that the very beginning
started out pretty strong especially
with the emblem customization here I got
pretty good as we went through the later
tiers of the blades of Persia battle
paths but personally I really still wish
that
Deb's would group up stuff especially
it's in the very apparent in the last
three pages here with the same exact
effect being in four different tiers but
a different faction I never understood
like there is no order for this they
just put the Vikings last and put the
samurai first for really no reason I
always really enjoyed about battle
passes that the higher tier stuff is
going to be of the highest tier at the
very end as you can see of course if we
get here - like tier 21 or in page 21 we
have the executions which is fair you
know that's at the very top but why is
the knights first and why is the woman
last there's no reason for them to be
first or last which is why I say they
should just belong in the same exact
tier so now the event passes over let's
talk about the weapons there's gonna be
some green gems in some of these weapons
and a lot of gold details with some
black and white is the main colors
you're going to be seeing it there's
very clearly a theme for this event
first up is Borden which is the favish
weapon set with some green gems on the
guard and hilt with the rest of it being
covered in gold the plate of some
serrated parts as well towards the
bottom to make it a little bit unique
conquerors thrall set has some white
accents to it the shield is definitely
the best part of the entire set and with
some nice-looking green gems from top to
bottom the weapon itself is more gold
than goes to black in the middle and in
some white at the bottom peacekeeper
shad ease set has the similar green gems
on the hill and guard for the weapons
the small dagger weapon is definitely my
personal favorite compared to the taller
bigger one the blue looks more close to
wardens weapon so that there is some
similarity there law bringers repped is
set the access to a nice black and gold
blends throughout the piece with some
minor green parts in the weapon
personally I think the green takes a bit
away from the weapon so personally not
my favorite Centurions Yasha
set also up the gate isn't too bad
either personally the silver part or the
blade ain't bad I would have preferred
more black though but I mean you got to
do what you got to do other than that
though it's a white hilt with a black
guards though not too bad gladiators a
Peloso set has some nice green gems as
well the shield was cool and but I
believe the sanguines omnia set would
fit really well since that main color
palette is gold and green just like the
weapon set so overall not too bad lastly
for the Knights is the black prior
Carina set the shield is amazing easily
one of the best things on the knight so
far in terms of secondary web
like the shield but I don't necessarily
like the main part of the weapon
especially that green part not the gems
but the regular coloring on the guard
just kind of really feels like it takes
away from the overall weapon so if that
was able to be replaced
I would have be totally fine with that
for the Vikings we have Raiders at night
at set also has some black and gold on
the outside with some white in the
middle and some nice blue gems in the
weapon as well warlords Macri has a
really nice looking weapon the shoe is
pretty good but the weapon is what
really caught my eye the shoe looks like
a giant wok pan though with the crazy
details that are really small but the
one thing I really appreciate about
warlords weapon is the very jagged edges
towards the grip which is really really
cool
berserkers areto set is a nice addition
to his weaponry as well just like the
past two characters although I
personally don't really enjoy that there
isn't much of a blend from gold to green
it's just one color to another color
there's no grading or kind of blend to
the color scheme at all but overall
though the blades are cool but the
handles are kind of met for me Valkyries
mainyu has some nice details on the
blade as usual for most of her weapons
and the shield is definitely a personal
favorite of mine but as for the weapon
the ends of it have some green gems and
there's some black and gold and some
white in the middle Highlanders Soroush
has a nice curve to it kind of like soon
das curvy blade he gets towards the
legendary tier and the guard is pretty
cool as well with some nice screen gems
and the handle is also green as well
shamans Khafre is a nice golden black to
it but personally in the weird bottom of
white Connor ruins it for the rest of me
I feel like de Blois to be dope with
other weapons but the handle really
bothers me so swapping out the handle
with another set of the weapons that she
has would probably be really good for
that lastly as arms ease Haase and
there's no white that I could notice
from here only black and gold with some
small green gems gotta admit pretty nice
weapon as the set altogether so
definitely a big plus for your manes
there for the same ride we have Ken
saison can Turris blade it's a nice
combo of green and gold I personally
would like to use it with the green but
as a whole set it looks nice and the
colors blend well shougo keys Opera is
another weapon of shoe goes with lots of
spikes on it like 95% of his event
weapons those flakes protrude out and
then go up on the piece and the top has
some green gems on it the rest is really
dope as well like usual Hiroshi's halma
set has some nice serrated parts towards
the bottom of the blade
probably the most amount of details I've
seen on a hill in a very long time so
that's definitely a positive for me boo
boo she's Vashta said is a very thinner
blade compared to her other weapons and
the rest is more of this silver cloudy
kind of color to it the green there's
some green in the middle
I'm very unsure about the color choice
with the silver but other than that not
too bad Shirley's daughter Vasa is some
more of inverted weapons that we've seen
a lot with other characters the top is
white and the bottom is green on the
left with the opposite for the other
weapon the green on top the white on
bottom the blade itself though looks
really cool and I personally am a big
fan of symmetrical weapons which is why
I don't really play these characters
that often so I'll have to pass on this
weapon for me personally
our musha's hasan has some white on the
guard with the other having black then
the blade has some nice waves on it
which would look really cool and
personally I like the black and gold
more than the white and gold and then
lastly for the samurai its hito kiri
serosa and it has some really nice dark
blue gems on it overall the piece is a
nice gold with some black colours on it
but overall I feel like because of the
fact of how big her weapon is I was
expecting more serration and wider
shapes to it but overall the rest is
really dope and I think you could
probably swap that headpiece for another
golden weapon in her sets of weapons so
not really too big of a deal
lastly coming on to the last five we
have the Wulin and t on DS eagle set has
a nice silver blade with some gold on
the garden blade the flaggin hill are
white which really don't blend it also
not really my favorite but the blade
itself are really cool JJ spent a set
has the blade are really huge with some
similar style to T&D silver and gold
blade but with some nice white and gold
on the staff part lucha's k Liana's
hooks are really nice I like the golden
green and I feel like they could fit
with some of the armors overall I do
prefer the green on her weapon as
opposed to the white and gold but I
never understood why some of these
characters like shinobi are Musha and
Nisha don't have the same color for some
of their weapons they always have to
have different colors that's always what
bothered me about these characters so
much Xiaolin Zenda staff has some gold
tips then it goes to black towards the
middle and then even closer towards the
middle we go to white and then back to
black in the very center of the piece so
unless a little blend of colors they're
not a bad piece but I don't really think
it'll fit overall with many of the
armors I feel like maybe the tops and
the bottom like the bonk part of the
staff
if you'll call it that it will work but
I think the shaft in itself probably
won't fit too well and then lastly is
soon da saga set the blade and guard go
really nice together with the golden
black finish but I feel like the hill
just kind of ruins it with this white
horse and green gem but personally like
I've said before with numerous
characters swapping this stuff out isn't
that big of a deal I just don't
understand why it's like that overall
though not too bad I'd say that these
weapons are really really cool I don't
think that they're gonna be fitting with
everybody's build in terms of their
character colors but I feel like these
aren't those bad of weapons that guys
that's going to be the end of the vid
say hopefully guys didn't enjoy like the
video if you did always think you do be
suffer providing me this early exit so I
can come up with these video ideas for
you guys but what that like to be if you
do enjoy a subscriber if you're new I
cover the informational side of fauna
that being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes in the leaks if
you want to kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
honor and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribe the channel
hi guys take her aggeridge today tell me
what you think about the event and peace
out
you
[Music]